[Music]
and I'm just an insignificant girl
that's what they want you to think
there's some blinkin you'll miss some
cameos I gotta know everything that went
into having Jai Courtney there for like
oh you know what it was just that
character is important in later stories
so we thought well it's hard to cast
somebody that's just gonna be there for
a blink but we'll try and convince them
you know that there would be a part
later it's kind of a strange proposition
you know but Jai was so great he was out
them do it so that's cool I've had
people do that for me before and then
they get when we do do the actual movie
they get blessed with this really
awesome part so sometimes it's kind of
smart to just kind of throw yourself
into a movie like that cuz it could pave
the way for a bigger role later yeah I
walked out I was like I just want to
make sure that was that was Jerry that
character jegan is like a god of those
motor ball games so we needed to find
somebody just got a badass and that we
can recognize because he's like his
works are and I assume there's a big
plan for ed Norton's Innovas the same
thing with that as another role you know
another role that was this is such a big
role later but we can't shortchange it
now or we're stuck with that person
later and Jim News Edie I knew ed we'd
never worked together before and he was
like the perfect choice for that kind of
mastermind type brain guys
[Music]